trump acknowledges his defeat and
pledges a peaceful transition of power
joe biden and kamala harris issue
divisive statements ripping the police
and facebook permanently bans trump
while leftists call for more censorship
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do keep
yourself safe
expressvpn.com slash ben we'll get to
all the news in just a moment and the
newsweek continues to be
extraordinarily packed and uh
devastatingly bad
basically across the board we'll get to
more of that in one second first a
reminder did you know that your family
can save over 800
a year just by switching to pure talk
from verizon at t or t-mobile think
about it what could your family do with
an extra 800
you don't have to sacrifice coverage
puretalk has the exact same coverage
same bars as one of the big carriers but
they are going to charge you half of
what you'd normally be paying one of
those giant carriers
and you don't have to sacrifice customer
service either their team is based right
here in the united states they're some
of the nicest people
you will ever talk to get unlimited talk
texts two gigs of data
for just 20 bucks a month if you go over
on data usage they're not gonna charge
you for it right now you're probably
paying for unlimited data you're not
using unlimited data because it is not
possible to use unlimited data
instead get two gigs of data plus
unlimited talk unlimited text
and if you go over on data usage you're
not going to be charged for it 20 bucks
a month grab your mobile phone dial
pound 250
say ben shapiro when you do you save 50
off your first month now pound 2 5 0
say my name ben shapiro pure talk is
simply smarter wireless you're really
spending too much on that telephone bill
right now and again
why not have the same coverage same bars
as one of the big carriers for like half
the price and
50 off your first month when you dial
pounds at 250 and say
bench bureau gets started with pure talk
usa right now okay so
here is the update on the news the
update on the news
overnight a capital police officer died
from injuries
that were sustained after clashing with
the with the mob over at the capitol
building according to nbc news
a u.s capitol police officer died
thursday after being injured in clashes
with pro-trump rioters in the capitol
the day before
officer brian sicknick was injured while
physically engaging with protesters
wednesday returned to his division
and then he collapsed he was taken to a
hospital he died about 9 30 p.m
on thursday signic joined at the capitol
police in 2008 he's the fifth person to
die from wednesday's violent clash
in washington of course there was a
woman who was shot to death by capitol
police
during the middle of the riot and then
there were three other people who died
of unspecified medical emergencies over
the course
of the riot his death will be
investigated by the metropolitan police
department
in washington siknik most recently
served in the capitol police
department's first responder unit
according to a statement from the
capitol police
news of the officer's death comes
shortly after capitol police chief
steven sund resigned amid criticism of
the department's response to rioters who
broke through the barricades vandalizing
the building and clashing
with police now as we now know we know
that mayor muriel bowser was not
interested in having a vast police
presence we know that the feds were also
concerned
about ticking off the protesters or
rioters or something which is
absolute insanity this is a failure at
every level there needs to be a full
investigation
as to why there were not more officers
on the grounds why the response took
hours on end and all those videos that
you have seen
of the officers removing barricades in
order to let people through it was not
in order to let people through it was
because they were consolidating their
lines
this will become relevant a little bit
later on in the program when we discuss
the pathetic notion that the police
treated these rioters with kid gloves
because they were white this has now
become the talking point du jour
of the democratic party and it's
disgusting we'll get to that in a moment
first other news there are a bunch of
trump cabinet officials who have now
resigned elaine chao who is the
secretary of transportation
and wife of mitch mcconnell the senate
majority leader temporarily
she has now resigned her post also betsy
devos resigned her post as well
ms devos said in a letter there's no
mistaking the impact your rhetoric had
on the situation is what she said to
president trump
she said we should be highlighting and
celebrating your administration's many
accomplishments on behalf of the
american people
instead we are left to clean up the mess
caused by violent protesters overrunning
the us capital in an attempt to
undermine the people's business that
behavior was unconscionable for our
country there's no mistaking
the impact your rhetoric had on the
situation that is the inflection point
for me naturally
the left is not meeting any of these
people with open arms they're not
suggesting
and never moderates neither of the media
nobody is suggesting that the folks who
are resigning from the trump
administration over this incident
ought to get any credit for doing so
instead because they were in the trump
administration in the first place the
idea is
that they are very bad and this lends
itself to the second narrative of the
day which is that if you voted for trump
if you're conservative in any way if you
don't believe any of the woke nonsense
pushed by the left
this means that you are part of the
problem you are equivalent to the people
who rioted and broke into the capitol
building now let me be clear about
something
the vast majority of people who are at
the protest are not even equivalent to
the rioters who broke into the capitol
building the vast majority of people
who went to that protest believed
something that was not true
about the voter fraud and voter
regulation voter regularity allegations
made by trump
many of them believed something that
wasn't true about the congressional
ability to overturn the election but
they were there because
they believed i think in certain
patriotic fashion
that the that the election ought to be
upheld in a true and proper way now
their definition of true and proper i
don't think was factually based but
those people were not the people who
were committing acts of criminality
there's about a couple thousand people
probably broke into the capital building
and to equate
even the tens or hundreds of thousands
of people who were at that
rally with trump to the people who broke
into the capitol building would be
conflating
everybody in a way that's not true so
certainly it's even more true that
people
who were not at the rally who did not
believe what trump was selling or what
josh halley was selling
all the people who did not believe that
the election was stolen and certainly
all the people who voted for trump are
not to blame for what happened here yet
that is the narrative that is being
drawn by the media
every good conservative is now being
lumped in with the people who decided to
violate
the heart of the democracy and by the
way it is more
i'm hearing some rumblings on the right
today well you know they just wrecked a
building what's the big deal i mean blm
wrecked buildings all throughout the
summer
and blm not only wrecked buildings they
put businesses out of business i mean
congress was back in session by the
evening
there's truth to that it also happens to
be the fact that this was an
insurrection because this was an
overt attempt to stop the business of
government from going forward
now is not a coup as some people have
been defining it because the military
was not involved there was no official
move to
attempt to remove the the senators there
was no
official attempt to actually overturn
the election that actually didn't happen
okay but the the basic notion here
that it was not a big deal that
obviously is not true either
so as always many things can be true at
once but the one thing that is certainly
true is that there's about 90
unity in this country i would zoom
higher maybe 95
unity that breaking into the capital
building and running roughshod through
that building is bad
and that is a problem as we'll see the
left is now refusing to acknowledge that
because the left sees a way to make a
political
gain here and the way to make a
political gain is to take
the bad people who broke into the
capitol building and did violence and
attack police officers and lump them in
with literally everybody on the right so
those are the two dueling narratives
that we're going to get
from the left over the coming months
over the coming years it's going to have
significant ramifications for your life
because what they're going to do is
they're going to suggest one that every
bad thing is part and parcel
of the white supremacist nation that is
the united states a point made by both
joe biden and kamal harris yesterday
these were the the captains of unity
they're going to bring the country
together right joe biden keeps saying
unity unity unity
and then he turns around and parrots
woke
okay so that's point number one and then
narrative number two is that everybody
on the right is guilty
for what happened that if you voted for
trump you knew this was going to happen
this is part and parcel of you
you wanted this to happen this is part
and parcel of of what was
what trumpism was right that simply
voting against the left
simply voting against joe biden and
kamala harris and aoc and nohan omar and
all the rest of the crew
that doing that meant that you were okay
with what happened at the capitol
building
that is the second narrative and that of
course is going to lead to censorship as
we'll get to
okay well the the big news of the day
amid all of this is that um the white
house
acknowledged that president trump had
lost the election again the reality is
that trump should have done this
months ago he had every opportunity to
explore every legal option
once the electoral college voted we were
done and once the states had certified
their votes within the safe harbor
provision by law there was no way to
overturn
the results of the election plus once
again
i know this is unpopular but it happens
to be the truth the trump campaign did
not provide the necessary evidence to
overturn any of the electoral results in
any of those states they just didn't
they had their hearings they had their
court hearings in many states they
didn't even allege that there was voter
fraud
that includes pennsylvania okay this
election
was over after the electoral college
voted okay
just as purely technically as possible
after the electoral college voted
the election was over okay but it is
good that the white house has now
acknowledged
that fact so yesterday kaylee mackinnani
the white house press secretary she got
up and she condemned the attack on the
capitol building
i am here to deliver this message on
behalf of the entire white house
let me be clear the violence we saw
yesterday at our nation's capital
was appalling reprehensible and
antithetical to the american way
we condemn it the president and this
administration
in the strongest possible terms it is
unacceptable
and those that broke the law should be
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law
okay and everybody was asking okay so
where's trump in all this
why doesn't trump say something well
last night trump did say something
after his twitter account was reinstated
he he put out a
two-minute 30 30-second video in which
he acknowledged that the election was
over and that he had lost
and that joe biden would be inaugurated
on january 20th he pledged himself to a
peaceful transition to power and he
ripped into the rioters
like all americans i am outraged by the
violence
lawlessness and mayhem i immediately
deployed the national guard
and federal law enforcement to secure
the building
and expel the intruders america is and
must always be a
nation of law and order the
demonstrators who
infiltrated the capital have defiled the
seat of american democracy
to those who engage in the acts of
violence and destruction
you do not represent our country and to
those who broke the law
you will pay okay and then president
trump went on
to acknowledge that he had in fact lost
the election and that joe biden was
going to be
inaugurated now congress has certified
the results
a new administration will be inaugurated
on january 20th
my focus now turns to ensuring a smooth
orderly and seamless transition of power
this moment calls for healing and
reconciliation
okay in just a second we're going to get
to the response by the left to all of
this
so now there's unity right unity should
break out
right we now have widespread unity
across the land rioting in the capitol
building is wrong
people should pay legally for breaking
into the capitol building
for threatening duly elected senators
congress people the vice president of
the united states for
attacking police officers one police
officer is dead
right there's widespread agreement about
all of these things
right the president has now acknowledged
that he lost the election he has
committed himself to a peaceful transfer
of power
which again should have happened weeks
ago but it's good that he's doing it now
obviously
so this should be a time of unity right
there should be a time when we all come
together because we all agree
there will be a transition to power on
january 20th the election has been
legally constituted
attacking the capital building is bad
right like all of these things are
perfectly obvious to when i say the vast
majority of americans i mean nearly all
americans at this point
right the country's ready to move
forward so you think the left is going
to uh allow this opportunity to
pass an untaken advantage of i think not
every crisis is an opportunity
when it comes to the left and that
includes the so-called unifying biden
administration we'll get to that in just
one moment because this is really truly
gross stuff we'll get to that in a
moment first let's talk about something
that's not gross let's talk about
something wonderful
something happy something distracting
i'm talking of course about waffles okay
so
i love waffles you love waffles who
doesn't love waffles only bad people
don't like waffles
every sunday morning this has become a
tradition now in the shapiro household
we break out
our presto stuffler stuffed waffle maker
this thing is magical okay so you pour
some batter
in the bottom of the waffle maker you
put in whatever filling you want could
be cheese it could be
strawberries blueberries candy and then
you pour a little more batter over the
top you flip it over you let it go for
10 minutes and you are getting delicious
restaurant-grade stuffed waffles better
you'll get at a restaurant you can make
it yourself
you make it healthy they even have you
know recipes out there for
no or low carb gluten-free keto batters
fill the thing with protein and veggies
if you want to be healthy about it
or if you want to be like my family does
then you know you do the decadent thing
and you put reese's peanut butter cups
in the middle of the
stuffer stuffed waffle maker and you
make yourself something absolutely
delicious
on a sunday morning and it's just
fantastic the presto stuffer works with
most any batter
instant box from scratch not just waffle
mixes cake muffin brownie cornbread
presto provides dozens of recipes ideas
for intriguing batters and delicious
fillings
it's an amazing awesome product go check
it out right this moment go to
www.stufflore that's
s-t-u-f-f-l-e-r.comstuffleur.com
click buy now add to cart enter promo
code ben
to get 10 off and free shipping that is
stuffler.com
promo code ben at checkout again that is
stufflore.com
promo code ben at checkout if you love
waffles you want to think about
something happy
make yourself happy today go to
software.com promo code ben to get 10
percent off and free shipping okay so
again this could have been the moment
right the moment where we all came
together because we're moving on right i
mean the trump
administration is done in less than two
weeks
right it's now january 8th the
inauguration is january 20th we have 12
days
until the inauguration and trump has now
pledged that he is going to hand over
power peacefully
which of course he should since every
single president in the history of the
united states has done so going back to
george washington
right and he has acknowledged the
results of the election he has
acknowledged that
that the electoral college has voted and
done its work
so we're done there and we're done with
the rioting because the reality is that
number one the police are actually going
to do their jobs at this time they're
going to be provided with the
with these sort of numbers they need in
order to quash all of this
and there's widespread sentiment on the
right
that this was deplorable and horrible
and bad and gross in every way that you
don't get to break into the capitol
building and threaten congress people
and attack police officers and do all
this kind of stuff
frankly i think there was an enormous
amount of shock on the reich that people
who even identified as right wing would
do this sort of stuff
i mean you'll remember back a few months
ago the typical thought on the right was
that
if biden lost that there would be riots
in the streets which by the way
certainly would have happened but that
front blossom probably would not be any
of that so i think a lot of people on
the right were duly shocked
to see what happened the other day and i
don't think they're wrong to be shocked
to see what happened the other day
obviously okay so that means that there
is widespread consensus
that bad things are bad and that good
things are good and that time moves on
and that there will be a new president
on january 20th right this would be the
moment when joe biden should come out
and he should say
we're all in agreement let's say this is
a dark day for the country now we can
move forward
together because we all agree that
people who violate
criminal law should go to jail instead
instead
joe biden and kamala harris decided to
go precisely the opposite direction they
decided that they were going to rip open
wounds for political gain
which is just awful behavior awful
behavior
okay it is it is terrible because again
these people are going to be in charge
of the executive branch of the federal
government for the next four years and
they are signifying
that in a moment when we could all come
together at a moment
when as they say that you know in their
belief the nightmare is over
bright new day dawning and all this
stuff right this is this is the
the biden line their claim
could have been okay well now we're
moving forward in unity arm and arm
this sort of stuff can happen again but
here's the problem the left
has allowed this sort of stuff to happen
for months just in a different context
right the left four months catered to
black lives matter rioters and
twenty-four writers in portland
for months they suggested that federal
officers on the ground in portland
were actually creating the problem even
though
the riots pre-existed the the federal
officers in portland and then
and then continued after the federal
officers left so
joe biden decided that it was time to
actually polarize the country still
further
because every crisis is an opportunity
so biden gave a speech yesterday in
which he attacked
trump and he didn't just suggest that
what trump had done over the last couple
of months was really bad
instead what he suggested is that trump
had launched an assault on our democracy
from the very beginning from the very
beginning of his administration right so
now the implication is that anyone in
either election 2016 or 2020 who
supported trump
should have known that this sort of
stuff was going to happen should have
known
that this was the way that things were
going to end everyone is guilty
everyone is guilty here is biden
effectually condemning half the country
i wish we could say we couldn't see it
coming
but that isn't true we could
see it coming the past four years we've
had a president
who's made his contempt for our
democracy our constitution
the rule of law clear
in everything he has done he unleashed
an all-out assault on our institutions
of our democracy from the outset
and yesterday was about the culmination
of that unrelenting attack
okay well i mean let's be realistic
about this as well there are folks on
the left cheering on the 16 19 riots
cheering them on
right nicole hannah jones said she was
proud that these were the 16 19 riots
and people were burning down businesses
and assaulting people
and in some cases you know killing
people in the case of david doran the
ex-police officer in st
louis the the the attacks on our
institutions are not
on one side here and the implication
here of course that biden is attempting
to draw
is that if you voted for trump because
you liked his policies or because he
didn't like what the left was presenting
then you were complicit in this because
you should have known all along it was
going to end with people breaching the
capitol building
in an incident that has no historic
parallel in the last
50 years i mean like what
okay so so the the only goal that what's
the goal there what's the goal there
like what's he attempting to do
what he's attempting to do pretty
obviously is polarize the country so
that he can suggest
that everybody who agrees with him is on
the side of the angels and everybody who
doesn't disagree with him is on the side
of the people who breach the capital
that's what he's attempting to do but he
goes even further joe biden
he goes even further because it's
important now not to polarize us only
along political lines but along racial
lines
so there was this woke bull talking
point that was going around yesterday
it was it was rocketing around cable
news was rocking around the internet
every nba player was tweeting it out and
this this nonsense point
was the idea that if these have been
black lives matter rioters who had tried
to break into the capitol building there
would have been mass carnage and mass
death and the police officers
treated everybody with kid gloves up on
capitol hill the other day
now this is a lie i mean it's just an
overt lie it's a lie number one because
the capitol police did not treat people
with kid gloves the other day
i mean according to reporters on the
ground ranging from tina wen over at
vanity fair
to julio rosas over town hall from the
left to the right there's widespread
acknowledgment police were firing tear
gas at people
the police were involved in physical
altercations with people the police were
drawing their weapons on people
a woman was shot to death in the halls
of the capitol
that is not treating with kid gloves and
all that video of
the police removing barricades they're
removing barricades because that is
typical security protocol if you don't
want the barricades used against you and
if you cannot consolidate your lines and
you don't have enough officers
people who are suggesting by the way why
weren't there more arrests made on site
because there weren't enough police
officers in the first place
when you arrest somebody the police
officer has to leave with the person
they are arresting
also all these people were on tape watch
in the coming days i'm sure there will
be dozens and dozens if not hundreds of
people
who are arrested for their activities in
the capitol building i would imagine
it'll be hundreds of people who are
arrested
for what they did in the capitol
building and as for the other side of
that coin that blm was treated with
some sort of market viciousness by the
police
throughout the country that's just a lie
it's not true washington dc had
widespread rioting
for days and weeks and widespread people
running roughshod through the streets
breaking into stores stealing things
assaulting people
we saw all the videos at the time you
know how many riders were killed by the
police during the washington dc protests
zero there were more people who were
killed during the capital
during the capital storming then were
killed during the washington riots
by the way i don't see anybody painting
a street in washington dc
q anon i don't see anybody painting a
street
in washington dc stop the steal
and yet when black lives matter riots
took over washington dc when they burned
a church
near the white house when they did all
that stuff
the mayor of dc muriel bowser ordered
that the words of black lives matter be
painted
in giant yellow letters visible from
space
on public streets she ordered that
applause would be renamed black lives
matter plaza
every corporation in america woke
scolded its own employees
and told them they needed to post black
squares in solidarity with the idea that
america is a systemically racist country
politicians from right to left put out
this
these nonsensical statements about how
america was cruel and vicious with
regard
to black americans meanwhile police were
defunded in cities across the country or
told to stand down
entire city streets in seattle were
turned over to the tender predations
of the folks of blm and antifa the city
of los angeles was shut down
for a week rodeo drive was closed at 1pm
so that blm rioters could run roughshod
through the city melrose avenue was
burned
so you're telling me that the cops were
vicious and brutal with blm rioters and
protesters
in what way in what way and as for the
media
the media treated these people as though
they were heroes chris cuomo asked why
should protests be non-violent
alexander ocado cortez she said you know
this is they're they're supposed to make
you uncomfortable that's the goal here
the entire culture swung behind blm
i was there the attempt to gaslight us
here by suggesting that everybody was
irreproachably tough on on blm
is such nonsense it's garbage there are
videos of police officers
kneeling with the protesters kneeling
with them don't give me that the police
officers at the capitol building one of
whom died
16 of whom were were injured that those
police officers were being super duper
kind to these people because they were
white
there were police officers who were
kneeling with the people
who were calling them systemically
racist
their mayors were going out into crowds
of people who were declaring that they
were
representatives of an evil system and
cow towing to them
there were there were white people who
were doing acts of
of supplication before black people
all over the country people literally on
their knees
in a in a mode of repentance to black
people even though they've never sinned
against a black person
and yet blm is the victim here you're
somehow you turn this into a racial
thing
how how and the only answer is when it
comes to the left
there's always just a couple of
arguments and i say that this this
whole situation has resulted in a couple
of arguments from the left right one is
that america's systemically racist and
the other is that conservatives should
be shut up
well dirty secret those are always the
same two answers for every leftist
problem
right it doesn't matter what the
predicate is the conclusion is always
the same
it's not if x then y if any letter then
y
right if the sky is blue today then
america is systemically racist and
conservatives should be shut up if you
didn't tie your shoes this morning then
america's systemically racist and you
should shut up
right these are these are the the
conclusions of
every single argument every single
one we'll get to joe biden doing this i
mean it's deeply divisive
crap it's deeply divisive this whole
this whole week has been so
disappointing and horrifying in every
way
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that you need to preserve your family
memories this is something important can
do for your family right
every ad is now like a breath of fresh
air i think
yeah the fact is that there's something
really nice because ads are about nice
things you can do for people here's a
nice thing you can do for somebody
you can make sure that their memories
are preserved so out in your garage you
have film it's falling apart you got old
pictures they're falling apart why not
have all that stuff digitized
and preserved forever start the new year
off right give your aging home movies
photos and film reels and modern updates
that they are organized and easy to
share with friends and family
did you know videotape recordings
weren't made to stand the test of time
they start diminishing after 10 to 15
years also you don't have vcr anymore so
why do you have vhs tapes with family
movies on them you're never going to be
able to watch them
legacy box makes reconnecting with your
past as easy as pressing play with
legacy box you can have all that footage
organized and preserved quickly and
easily the service is shockingly simple
you can use their kit to safely send the
moments you want preserved their
experience team
will create a digital collection by hand
and then it'll all come back to you
stored on the cloud thumb driver dvd
along with the original media you sent
with their tracking system you can
follow every step of the process so you
always know your original items are
secure over the past 10 years
legacy box has helped more than one
million families restore and protect
irreplaceable moments from the past
in 2020 legacy boxes services have
become so popular the team created an
additional 125 jobs at the preservation
studio here
in the u.s even if you want to do it
yourself it would cost hundreds of bucks
but when you visit legacy box today
you'll get 40 off you can get started
for as little as 39
for as little as 39 bucks go to
legacybox.com shapiro take advantage of
this limited time offer get 40
off the exclusive offer is not gonna
last long order their kit now send it in
whenever you are ready go to
legacybox.com
shapiro save 40 well supplies last at
shapiro okay so here is the uh
here's the rest of what joe biden had to
say so after suggesting that
trump launched an assault on democracy
from the very first day that he was in
office which means that all of his
voters should have known this was going
to happen they're all guilty along with
him
of everything that is going on this by
the way is not an uncommon talking point
on the left as we'll see
he also suggested that the capitol
police are viciously racist
now you may have looked at the uh at the
incident at the capitol and seen a bunch
of white people storming the capital one
of them getting shot
a bunch of people gonna get arrested and
you may have said yourself look it looks
like the capital police were overwhelmed
i can't believe they didn't have enough
people there
looks like security protocols need to be
overhauled or you could be an insane
person and suggest this has something to
do with systemic american racism
naturally joe biden is going to do the
latter
no one can tell me that it had been a
group of black lives matter protesting
yesterday
there wouldn't have been they wouldn't
have been treated very very
differently than the mob of thugs
that stormed the capitol well we all
know that's true
and it is unacceptable totally
unacceptable
no we don't all know that's true because
it's nonsense
it is nonsense the entire media
apparatus the entire governmental
apparatus cities around the country
allowed blm
free reign in their cities they painted
the city streets
they paid homage they marched with them
mitt romney was marching with blm for
god's sake
don't give me that blm that if blm had
done something like this
well that would have been i mean i can't
even imagine if blm had they burned
cities okay look what are you talking
about they ran roughshod through kenosha
and the media cheered the media
suggested this was all just an outburst
of passion
because of systemic american racism and
now you're saying this is somehow about
capital police being racist and then
kamala harris another unifying figure
get ready for the unity to break out by
the way again these two arguments are
are sort of the same right there is the
the america's systemically racist and
you should shut up
all of this is papered over with the
talk of unity because i'm not going to
unify with either of those propositions
but the idea is that if you don't unify
with those propositions you are the one
breaking unity
because it is perfectly obvious to
everyone that this was somehow about
race
in no way was this about race in like
what did the
what what okay but here is kamala harris
another deeply unifying figure
saying exactly the same thing we
witnessed two systems of justice of you
when we saw one that let extremists
storm the united states capital
and another that released tear gas
on peaceful protesters last summer
the american people have expressed
brightly
outrage we know
this is unacceptable we know
we should be better than this okay so i
have a question i mean really i have a
serious a logical question here
so according to kamala harris should the
police have used tear gas on the
protesters at both
or should they have used tear gas on the
protesters and neither
serious question because they you in
reality they use tier casts
on the protesters both right and the
rioters at both
right in reality the the police have
been pretty consistent
in in with regard to their use of force
here and they did use probably more
force with regard to the capitals
a person got shot and is dead they used
more force at the capitol than they did
with regards to blm protests all around
the nation
where there are pictures of cops
literally standing by and just letting
people run around burning businesses
okay but put that aside just on a purely
logical level
when she says that we have a double
system of justice here where protesters
were gassed in front of the white house
if they were blm
but then they were not gassed if they
stormed the capital is the idea here
that we should have let the people storm
the capital and we should have let
people protest
freely with burning churches near the
white house like which one is it
should we have tear gas both because
again
there's no logic to this the entire
thing is a divisive emotional appeal
designed
to suggest that everybody who supports
trump and supported trump back during
the election cycle no matter what he did
over the subsequent two months
and no matter what you said over the
subsequent two months and no matter
whether you think that the people who
breach the capital are idiots and
criminals that you
no matter what you do no matter what you
said you were complicit and not only
were you complicit
in the violence you are complicit in
racism right you are a racist as well
because america is racist as well
it's horror i mean this is it's
horrifying stuff because again this is a
moment where we should all
agree on the things i don't know how
many times over the past several years
i've said this where there's some
an issue that happens and i'm like you
know what seems like we should all be
able to agree on this and then you pull
americans and they do all agree on it
and then our politicians and i think
sometimes on both sides of the aisle
but at this point really on the left
with this kind of stuff
then the politicians immediately turn it
into something political right when it
comes to covet it was like why is this
political we're all trying to deal with
a global pandemic
and then immediately it turned into
america systemically racist like what
the what the hell
right again kovid the two solutions from
from the media and from your democratic
politicians were
america's systemically racist and shut
up when it comes to climate change it's
america is systemically racist and shut
up when it comes to tax policy it's
america it's systemically racist and
shut up
okay so in a second we're going to get
to the second message here which is shut
up
right we've done america systemically
racist now we're going to get to
shut up in just one moment first let us
talk about
something let us talk about something
new and wonderful
again every ad break is going to be a
breath of fresh air
throughout today's program and maybe
over the coming couple of weeks
let's talk about how you can get healthy
in an awesome awesome way
let's talk about staying in shape
nothing feels as good as that feeling of
accomplishment
of hitting your fitness goals feeling
great about yourself echelon echelon can
make it happen for you echelon offers
the next generation of connected fitness
bikes
fitness mirrors rowing machines and
their echelon stride smart treadmill no
matter what your favorite fitness
activity echelon will give you a fun
challenging workout from the comfort of
your home
the ex-7s is echelon's latest
state-of-the-art innovation that takes
cycling to the next level the ex-7s
connected bike it's built with
performance flexibility durability in
mind it's a bike for competitors at
heart they have world-class instructors
they're going to motivate you with
thousands of daily live and on-demand
studio level classes
always available when you need them
right now in many parts of the country
you can't go to the gym you need an
echelon bike echelon is just fantastic
and unlike their competitors
echelon is actually affordable you may
have looked at some of their competitors
and you're like whoa that's a lot of
money
not echelon one membership lets up to
five family members all work out at the
same time
right now you can try any echelon
fitness equipment at home for 30 days
so we have an echelon bike it has been
shipped to our house my wife is big into
the bike riding
echelon fitness is how she gets her
exercise done go to
n echelonfit.comfit.com it's a great way
to get in shape if you're if you're
somebody who's competitive
in the way that i am with regard to
sports the echelon classes
can help you with that you can burn off
your competition and burn off the
calories at the same time go check them
out right now
band that is echelonfit.com c e e c h e
l o n fit
dot com slash ben okay so the the second
part of the two step that has been
pushed here by the media
and it's been pushed by politicians is
shut up
right so so the first part was america's
systemically racist
and uh and conservatives are bad and the
conclusion of course
is shut up the conclusion is shut up so
trump has been banned from facebook
indefinitely
not only was trump banned from facebook
by the way so dan bongino
had his account removed on facebook
temporarily because he posted the video
of trump a couple of days ago during the
riot
talking about how he wanted people to go
home peacefully and then adding in a
bunch of stuff about how the election
was stolen
so just for reposting a video from the
president of the united states
for just reposting it his account was
removed facebook has now announced
that trump's account is going to be
completely removed from facebook now
look facebook is a private company
facebook can do whatever it wants to do
does that mean
that the spirit of free speech and civic
engagement can thrive
when you have big tech bros who have
decided what is available to you and
what is not available to you
and if you think this is going to stop
with trump you are dead wrong in a
second i'm going to show you how far
this is going to go
right the the truth is that jack dorsey
and and zuckerberg
they've had their fingers on the trigger
with regard to trump for a very very
long time
and we all knew that basically the day
after the inauguration both of them were
going to attempt to ban trump
well they're going to do it a little bit
early according to the washington post
zuckerberg said thursday the social
media giant is banning trump
indefinitely
marking a dramatic escalation of the
conflict between silicon valley and the
white house after trump weaponized the
web to help stoke a riot at the u.s
capitol that's the washington post
zuckerberg wrote we believe the risks of
allowing the president to continue to
use our service during this period are
simply too great
therefore we are extending the block we
have placed on his facebook and
instagram accounts indefinitely
and for at least the next two weeks
until the peaceful transition of power
is complete okay now you don't have to
agree with anything trump
has posted anything he has posted in
order to recognize this is a
a horrific precedent a really bad
precedent
imagine during those blm riots if
facebook had decided you know what
there's a lot of criminality and
violence that's going around right now
like a lot of it in fact so much so that
anybody who
even mildly excuses any of the
criminality or violence
anybody who tries to justify any of that
stuff even if they say stay peaceful but
they try to justify
that violence or they say the underlying
argument is good we'll just ban them
because after all the risk of
criminality is higher
than the value of the free speech right
how would that go you think that'd be
good for the country or very very bad
for the country
shutting down the modes and mechanisms
of conversation is a bad idea
if facebook believes itself to be an
open an open source for communication
opening minds to ideas it can't put
itself in the business of banning ideas
or banning figures even if facebook
doesn't like what they are saying
according to the washington post
facebook suspension mark the most
aggressive penalty any social media
company has meted out to trump
over his four-year term a period in
which he has repeatedly peddled
falsehoods attack critics and spread
divisive rhetoric online
twitter on wednesday also suspended
trump for 12 hours the company's first
ever blockade lifted on thursday morning
by evening trump resumed a tweeting
sharing a video that acknowledged the
new administration soon to be
inaugurated the tech giants took the
rare aggressive steps after a violent
mob stormed the house and senate
wednesday forcing lawmakers
into lockdown now the reality is that
if trump had won the election this
wouldn't happen right if trump had won
they wouldn't be banning his accounts
the reason they're banning his accounts
is because they are attempting
to in pretty cynical fashion stave off
legislation from a democrat-led senate
even if the republicans held the senate
i think that they probably wouldn't have
done this
the reason that they are doing this is
because they believe that if they
appease the democrats
if they start using their tech platforms
in order to shut down alternative points
of view
then the democrats will leave them alone
in other words if they just become part
of the mainstream
establishment media apparatus echoing
only the messages of the democratic
party
then the democrats will not regulate
them senator mark warner said well i'm
pleased to see social media platforms
like facebook twitter and youtube
take long belated steps to address the
president's sustained misuse of their
platforms to show discord and violence
these isolated actions are both too late
and not enough disinformation extremism
researchers have for years pointed to
broader
network-based exploitation of these
platforms there we go
that's where it is so mark warner is
saying basically anybody
who has ever in a video said anything
good about trump or even didn't say
anything about trump but somebody
watched their video and then watched a
trump video
we can look at the research the research
by the ways nonsense we can look at the
research and we can see
that these mainstream commentators you
know the jordan petersons or the dave
rubins or the ben shapiro's the glenn
backs
that all these people they're part of
the problem all you're gonna have to do
is just prevent all those people from
speaking freely on social media
it ain't gonna stop with trump it's
gonna start with trump
right jennifer palmieri hillary
clinton's former communications director
tweeted it does not escape my attention
that the day social media companies
decided there actually is more they
could do to police trump's destructive
behavior was the same day they learned
democrats would share all the
congressional committees that oversee
them she happens to be correct about
this
now facebook and twitter originally used
to make exceptions
for public figures with regard to some
of their rules which makes sense because
how exactly are we going to know what
they said and then hold them accountable
i mean it's amazing it truly is amazing
that the standards that are now being
set up
seem to assume there were no
repercussions to trump's behavior over
the past four years
he lost the election that seems like a
pretty major repercussion considering
that he is the first president to serve
only one term since george h.w bush and
the first president
since jimmy carter to serve only one
term
without a major third-party candidate
taking 15 20 of the vote
but this is what the media wants the
media are just this is the beginning
right this is the beginning
the beginning is they ban trump and then
they ban you that is the next thing
to happen for example the washington
post says even though facebook suspended
trump on thursday pro-trump pages and
groups with tens of thousands of members
including one called joe biden is not my
president which is hidden from public
view
quickly mobilized in support facebook
has cracked down on some of the most
pervasive and violent conspiracy
theories
the social media company's belated
efforts have also had the effect of
pushing many of the group's leaders
to alternative social platforms like
parlor joan donovan research director at
harvard kennedy's
school's shorenstein center on media
politics and public policy said quote
he's part of a much larger system of
disinformation as a result taking action
against trump
is symbolic in some ways but unless they
consistently apply these rules to media
manipulators and dis-informers this is
going to keep happening
uh there we go so bottom line is ban
everyone
ban everyone so who does the washington
post quote
as they source for this stuff media
matters they quote media matters in this
article
an activist left-wing group originally
set up by hillary clinton's team the
podestas
it's it's so this is the next step right
you are a racist because what happened
in the capital
you are a bigot and viciously in favor
of violence
if you voted for trump and now you
should be banned consequently
we'll explain in just one second first
let us talk
about the fact that right now you might
be looking at the world and thinking to
yourself well it seems like things are
collapsing i hope that i am safe and
secure
in my home as a law abiding american
citizen who believes in the
constitutional right to keep and bear
arms
well when the founders wrote the
constitution the first thing they did
was make sacred the right of the
individual to share their ideas without
limitation
the second thing they did was secure the
right of individuals to protect
themselves and their lives with force if
necessary
owning a rifle and using it in legal
ways is a heavy responsibility
building a rifle is no different bravo
company manufacturing builds a
professional-grade product which is
built to combat standards this is
because bcm believes the same level of
protection should be provided to every
american
regardless if they are a private citizen
or a professional the people at bcm
assume that when a rifle leaves their
shop
it could be used in a life or death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer
or a soldier overseas with that in mind
every component of a bcm rifle is hand
assembled
and tested by americans the people at
bcm feel it is their moral
responsibility as americans to provide
tools
that will not fail the user when god
forbid they need to protect
themselves to learn more about bravo
company manufacturing head on over to
bravo company
mfg.com you can discover more about
their products special offers upcoming
news that is bravo company mfg dot
bcm knows making reliable life-saving
tools that's only half the story
the company works with leading
instructors of marksmanship from top
levels of america's special ops forces
for marine corps force reconnaissance
us army special ops forces connecting
them with other americans they will
teach you the skills necessary to defend
yourself
your family or others go check them out
right now and check them out not just at
bravocompanymfge.com but at youtube.com
bravo company usa go check them out
right now
in just a second we'll get to michelle
obama and the continuing call to shut
down
all free speech on the basis of what
happened
this week first a bit of relief it's
that glorious time of the week when i
give a shout out to a daily where i
remember today
is ryan duffy husband father carpenter
marine vet on instagram who understands
the secret to working at long hours in
this picture
the company the world's greatest
beverage vessel is in a workshop
filled with cabinets being sanded before
assembly around a fireplace the caption
reads
it's going to be another late night as a
small business owner i know that these
come more often than it seems they
should but it's okay
i am armed with a great cup of hashtag
leftist tears in my new
real daily wear left his fears tumbler
hot or cold i'm ready to complete my
project
excellent excellent keep up that good
work thanks for the pic thank you for
your service
also you may have noticed that there is
a tsunami of culture that is directed
explicitly against you it's going to get
worse not better over the coming years
with the biden harris administration
what we are going to see is a tsunami of
outrage and anybody who disagrees
and the entertainment industry that
feeds and mainlines this crap into the
bloodstream of american politics
is just gonna get worse and worse it's
gonna get more and more toxic that's why
we are pushing back against
cultural blacklisting on friday january
15th dailywire is releasing its first
feature film run hide fight exclusively
to daily wire members
run hide fight is not particularly
political it is intense it does have a
powerful message the movie follows a
high school besieged by a quartet of
school shooters
a young girl 17 year old zoe hull uses
her wits and survival skills to fight
back
here is a bit of the trailer
in between breath take the shot
he's doing really good out there kid
size of that deer we're going to be
eating venison all summer
well the days work i think we need to
see somebody again and by what you mean
me
no i mean us hey that look in your eye
guys in my evening at that location
maybe there's a brochure you can have me
so i can go
is that chris angelic over there is he
doing something completely weird
senior prank day but we'll see all kinds
of dumb stuff today swim captain we'll
have
typhoo delivered to class and becky
vaughan will set up our homemade slip
and slide this is high school
nothing that happens to your matters in
the real world
[Music]
okay we are in charge now so please pull
out whichever app you use to do live
streaming video get them up and running
and point it at me
now
get down on the ground any more friends
back there
i'm calling 911
you must be close
[Music]
you should be ashamed
very disturbing news out of vernon
central high school
[Music]
zoe
in between breath take a shot
go is it safe to say that this might be
our guardian angel
do you want more people to die that's
the last thing i want i'm gonna kill one
person in this room every five minutes
you don't show your face
isn't it ironic that after all your hard
work
people aren't gonna remember you
no you're gonna remember me
it's it's awesome it's edgy it is rated
r i'm just telling you right now because
we need to compete in the space we need
to provide people alternatives
to the leftist crap that they are
getting from amazon or netflix or
anywhere else they get their
entertainment to mark the release we're
going to be doing a live stream premiere
the night before
thursday january 14th during a special
episode of backstage featuring jeremy
boring
me some special guests come join us as
we put culture
back in conservative categories come
join us as we try to infiltrate the
culture
and fight back you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so as i keep saying there are a few
messages that are coming out here
after this this terrible terrible week
message number one from biden harris
is that if you voted for trump or if you
supported trump or if you don't back
their agenda then this is because you're
in favor of what happened
number two is that america is
systemically racist and its police are
systemically racist which is one hell of
a message to put out after a police
officer dies
defending the capital which is what
happened this week
and message number three is that you
should all shut the hell up and shut up
and not only that there should be
forcible attempts to shut you up it's
not just that you should be quiet it's
that there should be
companies geared towards shutting you up
that all the companies should basically
stop doing business with you
that that everybody should stop allowing
you a platform michelle obama
queen of light and wonder she put out a
statement yesterday here's what it said
i woke up yesterday elated by the news
of reverend rafael warnock's election
victory he'll be george's first black
senator
i was heartened by the idea that the
senior pastor of ebenezer baptist church
the home parish of dr king
and a spiritual and organizational hub
during the civil rights movement would
be representing his state
in the united states senate in just a
few hours my heart had fallen harder and
faster than i can remember like all of
you
i watched as a gang organized violent
mad they'd lost an election laid siege
to the united states capital the day was
a fulfillment of the wishes of an
infantile unpatriotic president
who can't handle the truth of his own
failures the wreckage lays at the feet
of a party and media apparatus that
gleefully cheered him on knowing full
well the possibility of consequences
like these
uh so here's here's where we go right is
that everybody knew everybody knew this
is going to be
the revisionist history here is that
everybody knew that the capital was
going to be stormed
right okay well if that's the way that
we're going to play this game then
everybody knew that a police officer
that six
dallas police officers are gonna be shot
to death by a blm activist
during obama's administration i mean
with rhetoric saying that america was
systemically racist and the police
were systemically racist i mean
everybody knew that it was gonna come to
this
right if we're gonna play this game
everybody knew they're gonna be riots in
ferguson everybody knew they're gonna be
riots in washington dc
everybody knew that businesses were
gonna get burned and looted all around
the country this summer everybody knew
all that stuff
okay that's not how this game gets
played okay free speech is free speech
okay that you don't get to suggest that
everybody who speaks freely on a topic
of consequence
is now responsible for nut jobs doing a
nut thing
because they believed lies okay but here
is michelle obama continuing because she
has some answers for you she has some
some suggested ways that we can prevent
this in the future
she says it left me with so many
questions questions about the future
questions about security extremism
propaganda and more but there's one
question i can't shake what if those
writers
look like the folks who go to ebenezer
baptist church every sunday what would
have been different
and so there's the uh the biden harris
message that the police are racist
i think we all know the answer we do
because we watched what happened over
the summer 16 to 25 million americans
protested
and um the police basically laid off of
them this summer's black lives
they keep saying things like oh 14 000
people were arrested over the course of
the protest oh you mean the months-long
protests
slash riots there were 500 riots all
across the country
statistically speaking there were 16 to
25 million
people who are involved in the protests
okay in any case she says this summer's
black lives matter protests were an
overwhelmingly peaceful movement right
so here's the revisionist history
our nation's largest demonstrations ever
bringing together people of every race
in class encouraging millions to
re-examine their own assumptions and
behavior and yet
in city after city day after day we saw
peaceful protesters met with brute force
we saw cracked skulls and mass arrests
law enforcement pepper spraying its way
through a peaceful demonstration for a
presidential photo op and for those who
call others unpatriotic for simply
taking a knee in silent protest for
those who wonder why we need to be
reminded that black lives matter at all
yesterday made it painfully clear that
certain americans in fact are allowed to
denigrate the flag and symbols of our
nation they've just got to look the
right way who's allowed to do that those
people are going to be arrested
capital police officers shot a woman she
died
okay like who was allowed to do this who
is saying that this is a great thing
who who okay this is just a made-up bull
it's a nonsense narrative
it's nonsense and it's insulting to the
intelligence and it's insulting to the
american people
it's insulting by the way to suggest
that the cops were vicious and brutal
with black lives matters protesters all
over the country again
16 to 25 million people marched
by the way i can say both can i not i
can say that it is unpatriotic and
terrible and un-american as i have to
storm at the capitol building
to interrupt the process i've called it
insurrectionary because it is
i can also say that taking a knee for
the american flag to suggest that
america stands for
systemic barbarity and racism is also
not a pro-america sentiment can i not
can i can i do both how about that how
about that
but it's one and not the other when it
comes to democrats
what do these folks have to say now says
michelle obama seeing the gulf between
the responses to yesterday's riot and
the summer's peaceful protest and the
larger movement for racial justice is so
painful
it hurts and i cannot think about moving
on or turning the page uh-huh
until we reckon with the reality of what
we saw yesterday true progress will be
possible only once we acknowledge that
this disconnect exists
and takes steps to repair it and that
means coming to grips with the reality
that millions voted for a man so
obviously willing to burn our democracy
down for his ego ah
every single person who voted for trump
is in favor of people storming the
capitol building
that's what michelle obama's saying so
we've got both messages now right we've
got the message
that the cops are racist and america is
racist and also
that every single person who voted for
trump every single person who didn't
vote for joe biden
every single one of those people is
deplorable and awful and evil
i hurt for our country says michelle
obama i wish i had all the solutions i
wish i had the confidence that people
who know better will act like it for
more than a news cycle or two
all i know is that now is a time for
true patriotism
now is the time for those who voted for
this president to see the reality of
what they've enabled and publicly and
forcefully
rebuke him in the actions of them up
okay everybody did now is the time
for silicon valley companies to stop
enabling this monstrous behavior
and go even further than they already
have by permanently banning this man
from their platforms and putting in
place policies
to prevent their technology by from
being used by the nation's leaders to
fuel
insurrection okay but she doesn't stop
there
she says it now is a time for swift and
serious consequences for the failure of
leadership
that led to yesterday's shame
okay so she she then calls for basically
everybody be punished right everybody
needs to be punished
i love this she says together john
ossoff
and raphael warnock will give control of
congress back to the only party that's
shown it can put democracy above its own
short-term political fortunes
she's literally literally undermining
comedy and unity in the republic in
order to benefit democrats short-term
political fortunes that's what she is
doing here
so we have to hold tight to our values
by banning people that's that sounds
good we'll hold tight to our values by
banning people it's not just michelle
obama of course
uh oliver darcy over at cnn he uh he put
out a social
he puts out a social media newsletter
and and he had these paragraphs
he says we regularly discuss what big
tech companies have done to poison the
public conversation by providing large
platforms to bad faith actors who lie
misleading promote conspiracy theories
what about tv companies that provide
platforms to networks like newsmax one
america news
and yes fox news so now oliver is
calling
for tv companies to ban the distribution
of fox news on the basis of this
he says sean hannity tucker carlson mark
levin and others are responsible for the
lies they peddled to their audiences
but the tv companies that beam them into
millions of homes around the country
also bear some responsibility
and yet we rarely if ever talk about
them it is time
tv carriers face questions for lending
their platforms to dishonest companies
that profit off of disinformation and
conspiracy theories
oh you mean like dishonest companies
like i don't know cnn
cnn which spent years promoting the uh
the idea that donald trump was a russian
plant
okay the washington post put out an
editorial saying much of the same kind
of stuff
they say that we now need to stop the
spread of misinformation
on social media right the burden rests
with the sites that allowed
bad actors to warp the worlds of so many
citizens they must stop the spread of
misinformation according to clear rules
that stem from clear principles they
must promote accurate information in the
manner the evidence tells us is most
likely to persuade
both of these undertakings will likely
require some trial and error
so wait a second it was it's almost as
though the same exact solution that the
left has always called for namely
repressive tolerance shutting down other
points of view
is now going to be extended to meet this
supposed this supposed crisis right
that's that's what's going to happen
right we're going to shut down free
speech
joy behar makes it even clearer because
of course she's basically you take all
of the democratic
talking and you boil it down to one
bumper sticker and that's joy behar so
here's joy behind yesterday on the view
saying the media on the right
has to be sanctioned i have always said
from the very beginning that the lying
is the biggest
problem because look at where it has
brought these people
and one more thing how is that going to
happen because you have somebody like
matt
gates saying that in what it was anti
for people
dressed as protesters this is never
going to get settled they are the
biggest
liars they have these people i guess
have to be taken down
right and and and then the media on the
right also has to be
sanctioned the media on the right has to
be sanctioned
anybody who prints something that joy
behar doesn't like has to be sanctioned
and unless you think that these are just
going they're going to restrict it to
the outliers to the to the fringe people
yeah
sure sure they are david hogg another
bumper sticker leftist
he tweeted out there should be a public
list of companies that hire the trump
enablers after this so we can all
boycott them
yep that's where this is going that's
where this is going
cory bush the the congresswoman the the
blm congresswoman she suggested that
every single republican
should be removed from office all the
republicans should just be removed from
office here she was yesterday on msnbc
we need to call it what it is it's white
supremacy it was white privilege
and it was the call of our president and
it was encouraged by our republican
colleagues and that is why every single
one of them especially because
they have been the ones trying to steal
this election that's why we are calling
for them to be removed
they should not be seated right all the
republicans none of the republicans
should be seated that's the solution
so the solution to an attempted
insurrection is to shut down free speech
and boot out everyone who disagrees with
me in congress sounds perfectly american
to me
sounds great sounds great alrighty so
it's been an incredibly incredibly rough
week like a very very rough week for the
country a very rough week for
conservatives
and for people who like basic rights and
civility and decency it's been a very
rough week
so let's end with a little bit of bible
talk here so this
week's this week the jews right as i
explain every week the jews read a
portion of the bible every single week
and uh the portion of the bible that
they read this week
is the portion that begins the book of
exodus in hebrew
the book of exodus is known as the book
of shemos or shmot
and and the the book of exodus begins
with the story of moses
and so i want to focus in for a second
on the portion of this
week's parsha about the burning bush so
here's what the bible has to say about
when when moses
comes essentially face to face with god
or at least uh face to bush
or face to burning bush with god uh so
here is uh
here is what the bible has to say is
exodus chapter 3
beginning verse 2. an angel of the lord
appeared to him in a blazing fire out of
a bush
he gazed there was a bush all a flame
but the bush was not consumed
moses said i must turn aside to look at
this marvelous sight why doesn't the
bush burn up
when the lord saw that he had turned
aside to look god called him out of the
bush moses moses
and he answered here i am okay so to
understand what's going on here you have
to understand that the basic idea of the
burning bush is you have
a material thing right a thing that is
temporary and of this world
and there's a flame that should be
consuming it but the thing is not
consumed this is signification of the
eternal
right time moves on time destroys but
there are certain things that are not
destroyed
and a certain thing is is god right and
um and moses is answering in the
language of supplication right he's
hineny which is the same sort of
language that abraham uses with regard
to god when god calls him to to
make a sacrifice of his son isaac the
bible continues god said do not come
closer remove your sandals from your
feet for the place on which you stand is
holy ground
i am said god the god of your father the
god of abraham the god of isaac the god
of jacob
moses hit his face for he was afraid to
look at god and the lord continued
i've marked well the plight of my people
in egypt i've heeded their outcry
because of their task masters yes
i am mindful of their sufferings i've
come down to rescue them
from the egyptians okay and um
and then moses says to god when i come
to the israelites and say to them the
god of your fathers has sent you and
they asked me what is his name
what shall i say to them so in the bible
names have deep meaning
in the bible names are supposed to
convey something true about the person
that's why in the bible so often you'll
see somebody named and it'll explain the
meaning of the name like when we pick
we do the same thing with our kids when
we pick a name for our children we try
to
encapsulate a meaning for the child that
we hope for their life or or their
relationship with god
so the same thing is true in the bible's
regard to name so there's very
there are several different names of god
that are used in the bible and
the name that god suggests be used here
is actually this is the only time i'm
aware that it's used anywhere in the
bible
the name that god suggests to moses be
used with regards to the
the the jews in in egypt so
moses says what should i say your name
is and god says
right which which literally means i will
be what i will be
right he continued and you will say to
them
right you shall yeah sent me to you
okay so that's kind of a weird sentence
right because god is saying to moses
his name right hey yeah yeah i am i will
be what i will be
and then when you go down to them though
i don't want you to say yeah yeah i want
you to say
hey yeah right just just the first one i
just i will be
okay so the talmud discusses what the
meaning of this is and the idea is
i will be a savior for you now and i
will be a savior for you in the future
right
yeah because twice i will be for you now
i'll share yeah
what i will be for you in the future and
moses says the talmud says back to god
i'm not sure that people can handle the
fact that there's gonna be bad news in
the future you're talking about the
redemption right now and then god says
back to him
well then just tell them i will be
meaning that you're about to be redeemed
right i will be
and then god says further to moses you
shall speak to them and say the lord the
god of your fathers the god of abraham
the god of isaac the god of jacob sent
me to you this shall be my name forever
this
is my name from generation to generation
right so the answer that god is giving
here is that
the trials and tribulations they don't
end right yeah
god will be that god is the eternal rock
he doesn't change he is there for you
in times both good and bad and there is
no such thing as the end of history
there is just more history right there
is just the the continuation of things
that happen there is redemption
there are cycles things rise things fall
there will be trials in the future but
any time there's a dark period
remember that time is moving yeah right
what you need to keep in mind when
you're in a dark period
is not yeah yeah that god is gonna help
you now and they're gonna be tough times
in the future and he's gonna help you
then too
what you need to remember is that right
now in the darkest periods
god is there for us god remembers us god
recognizes us
god wants things to be better for us he
wants us to act with dignity
he wants us to act with decency he wants
us to act as though our lives and our
decisions matter
and god will be there with us god will
redeem us and yes that doesn't mean
that there will be any sort of utopia in
which all bad things stop
bad things will continue to happen and
down the road there will be more bad
things
but just remember that for right now the
same god that brought
us the united states through the
revolutionary war that brought us
through the civil war
the same god that helped the united
states overcome
the tyranny of the nazis the same god
that helped the united states overcome
the hatred in its own heart
the the evils of segregation and jim
crow that same god is going to help us
overcome evils that we see in our own
hearts
and the divisions of our own country god
is going to help us overcome that now
and what comes later god will be there
for that too but the important thing is
remember right now
it's not that all hope is lost it's that
maybe we're putting our hope
in the wrong place okay we'll be back
here a little bit later next week
and with an additional hour of the bench
shapiro show later today in the meantime
go check out the michael knowles show
that is available
right now you're listening to the bench
bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producers are
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager pavo wiedowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
joe biden stokes racial tensions big
tech bans president trump and another
kooky white lady pretends to be hispanic
check it out on the michael knowles show
[Music]